i declare that andy burnham is duly
elected as the mayor of the greater
manchester combined authority
andy burnham there you can see the
smiles elected as
the mayor of greater manchester he holds
on no surprise there let's have a listen
to what he's got to say
um firstly can i start by thanking the
council
staff and volunteers both at the polling
stations and all of the counts and all
of the team
here it's been a long slog for them uh
and we appreciate them uh and all the
work that they've done
thanks to the colleagues from greater
manchester police who've
seen good order and all the security
staff here as well
uh today can i thank all of the other
candidates
for standing in this race because
it helps build devolution in greater
manchester the fact that so many people
have taken part but i particularly would
like to thank
melanie horrocks from the green party
and simon lapori
for attending pretty much every hustings
that we did together
and that was important but more than
that for the way in which
we conducted things yes you challenged
me rightly so
but we conducted the debate in the right
way and both of you did
um and a pilot for bikes on trams might
just be a bit of labor green cooperation
that comes out of this
this mayoral election um
can i thank uh my uh campaign team my
brilliant campaign team
for a powerful positive uh campaign
and the endorsements that i had from
sally and chris
and i'll just say this as well god bless
the band
if you know you know i'll just leave it
there
my family marry france jimmy
rosie annie
thank you all for your patience your
guidance
your love and your support
my mum and dad nick and john thank you
for the values you've given me
the general approach to life that has
taken me to this point on this stage
today my main thanks though go to the
wonderful
wonderful people of greater manchester
i value every single vote
you have given me i know
that people who normally support other
parties have voted for me
i will always remember that and respect
it
i will continue to be a voice for all
people
and all communities i will continue to
adopt
a place first not party first approach
where the government gets it right and
treats us fairly i will work with them
but where they don't
i will challenge them for you as
forcefully
as i can greater manchester expects
nothing less this
vote sends a clear message to all
westminster parties people are buying in
to english devolution they are
telling you to deliver more of it
not less they like us having the ability
to do more for ourselves to do things
that are right
for greater manchester they can see
how it's making politics work better
for them and that is reflected in the
council results
across greater manchester they value
the stronger voice that it's given
to the north of england and they expect
us to use it
don't give us evolution and be surprised
if we answer you back
particularly if you do things here that
you would never dare to do in london
and people are saying that they want the
leveling up
that has been promised i read this week
that there is
quote widespread cluelessness within the
government
about what leveling up means so
here is where i can help you prime
minister
let me define it it can't be achieved by
scattering funds
across a few favored places
it can be achieved when you give
millions
of people in a city region like this one
a modern affordable public transport
system
when it costs the same to catch a bus
in harper hay as it does in haringey
one pound 55 not four pounds or more
that people pay here leveling up is
achieved when you give
all people the dignity of decent
work with wages that don't have to be
topped up
by visits to the food bank and when we
have the kind of
jobs here which means our young people
don't have to move
south to get on in life which i had to
do
30 years ago and leveling up is achieved
when every single one of our fellow
citizens
has the foundation of a good secure
home beneath them better jobs
better homes better transport
these will be my top priorities we will
hit the ground
running next week with major moves on
all three
starting on monday with transport
this is a resounding mandate to bring
our buses back under public control
the greater manchester public have
called time
on 35 years of bus companies
having the run of the road of rising
fares
and of routes being cut make no mistake
we are going to build the bee network
a london-style public transport system
with london
level fares it will create the
foundation
for a more productive economy and it
will connect our residents
to opportunity to the bus companies i
say
respect democracy and do not stand
in our way to the prime minister i say
work with us make it happen more quickly
show us your serious about leveling us
up with london
it's in your interests and it's in ours
the time for debates is over it is time
to deliver we are building the new
greater manchester and from now it goes
faster
this is our place this
is our time